- Tiffany G7, why do men have nipples?
(sighs) Tiffany, come on!
You gonna ask me the hard
questions? (upbeat music)
Hey guys, what is up?
My god, the channel is growing so fast
and I'm here with another episode
of responding to your comments.
I'm really loving the interaction
and growth that's
happening on the channel.
I mean you guys are killing it!
The medical reaction series is like whoa!
Grey's Anatomy just hit 10 million views!
Subscribe, subscribe, subscribe
'cause that tells YouTube
that you're really enjoying the channel.
So let's get started.
Time to respond and read some
comments. (mimics gunshot)
Why do men have nipples?
This is not something they
taught us in medical school.
And I hate when people say that!
They're like, "Mike, you don't know that?
"They didn't teach you
that in medical school?"
No, I didn't have men's nipples 101
as one of my classes that I was taking.
I was taking pathophysiology
and microbiology
and pharmacology, learning about
how drugs enter your system
and how they leave your system.
Much more complex stuff than that.
But I guess I should probably look
into why men have nipples.
Interesting question, Tiffany.
I'll get back to you on that. (laughs)
This has always killed me
and I wanna know your opinion on this.
Doctors and nurses see
the effects cancer has
on the body so why do
so many of them smoke?
Mihai, what a great, great question.
You know what's funny, Mihai?
My father, who is a doctor,
I've mentioned it before,
actually smoked for about 10 years
when he was younger, up until
the time he became a doctor
and started to see the consequences
of smoking and immediately stopped.
But there a lot of doctors who
because of their very stressful lives
because of the burnout
that they experience
in their hectic day-to-day job,
actually start smoking or
maybe even continue smoking.
It's a horrible habit and just
because you know that
it shortens your life,
just because you know it can bring disease
doesn't always convince
people to not smoke.
I will say this, smoking
rate's at an all-time low.
The percentage of smokers
has dropped into the teens
and that's such a huge
accomplishment for the United States.
In pain, is that really your user name?
In pain, I hope you're not in pain.
How long did it take you to
get used to the sight of blood
or were you fine with it from the start?
Have any of the procedures
you've done make you nauseous
or even come back to
haunt you in your dreams?
Oh my god, this is such a great question.
Blood never made me nauseous.
I always just viewed it as part of the job
and it didn't phase me in any way really.
I will tell you I have
a thing with gagging.
You know when you go see the dentist
and they put the dental mold on you?
I mean I've had braces twice.
So I've had those molds put in a ton.
I get the biggest anxiety
when they put the molds in
because I could feel the
mold scratch the back
of my throat and it
triggers my gag reflex.
It gives me the most anxiety and I have
to literally sit there
and put all my willpower
to make sure that I don't
freak out having the mold
in my mouth.
And I guess from that
there is a procedure we do
in the hospital called the
nasogastric tube insertion.
It's basically you put in a tube
that goes in through the nose
and it goes into the stomach.
We can use that to feed the patients
that are unable to swallow.
We can use it to pull
content out of the stomach
for suctioning purposes.
Sometimes patients gag.
Something to do with
gagging makes me gag also.
So please no.
I'm getting nauseous thinking about it.
We have to stop this question right now.
Everything wrong with my channel.
(laughs) What?
My doctor's an old Chinese man
who tells me I need to get married soon.
Still grateful though.
Should you get married?
I don't know.
What's your life like?
Are you happy with your partner?
Do you have a partner?
Do you wanna get married?
Who's this old Chinese man?
Annakah, what's your opinion on vaping?
(sighs) I'm probably gonna get torn apart
for this because I am not a fan of vaping.
Even though a lot of these
companies like Juul are coming
out and saying that their
products are an alternative
to smoking, what the
evidence has shown so far is
that people who don't smoke
start vaping, especially kids.
And, yes, they've put some money
towards making sure that kids don't start
by advertising the dangers of vaping
and making sure it's
not advertised to kids.
But in reality, kids
are gonna start doing it
because they make
flavors like cotton candy
and bubble gum, like of
course kids are gonna do it.
So no, I am not a fan of vaping.
I will go on record and
say it's probably not
as hazardous as traditional
smoking cigarettes.
But it still has chemicals.
You're still inhaling chemicals.
Some of the flavors have propylene glycol
in them, which has been known
to cause a condition called popcorn lung.
I mean, you don't want
any of these conditions.
And in reality the thing that makes all
of these substances dangerous,
whether you're talking about cigarettes
or vaping is nicotine.
Nicotine is an addictive substance.
It constricts your blood vessels,
which can cause an array of problems
from having a stroke,
from having heart attacks.
This is not something
you want for your body!
If you're gonna use a vape pen
to gradually get off cigarettes, okay.
Then that's fine but there's
no other use for them.
You shouldn't just use
them for your pleasure.
That's just my take.
Rey Ocasio, can you confirm
or deny the conception
that pimping ain't easy?
It ain't easy, but it ain't right either.
If you're pimping in the literal sense,
you should be in jail.
And if you're pimping 'cause you got swag
and all that, that still
ain't easy so props to you?
Aleeza Humayun, do you have
good handwriting or not?
Please like so he sees this message.
Well, you didn't have to like it
'cause I saw the message and
I'm gonna answer you honestly.
I got grades, but in cursive,
I got my lowest grades.
I mean my mom had to sit there
with me teaching me how to write in script
'cause I was so bad!
I couldn't stay within the lines
and the spaces and half of
the letters would be capitals,
half of them would be lowercase.
I have the traditional
doctor's handwriting.
This was even a joke.
I remember at my Taekwondo school,
when I filled out the applications
for tournaments, people would say,
"Oh my god, look his dad's a doctor.
"He has doctor's handwriting."
So no, my handwriting is bad.
But I will say I worked really
hard to make it legible.
So you can read it,
but it looks like a third grader wrote it.
Samtaplet2, can doctors
diagnose themselves
and prescribe themselves medication?
Um, Sam it's not illegal for doctors
to prescribe themselves medication
but it's ethically questionable.
So doctors generally shouldn't do it
but I mean if you need
to write yourself an allergy medication
or an antibiotic, it's
really not a big deal.
But I will say this, you're
not being the best doctor,
the most objective doctor,
when you're treating yourself
because you often think
you know what's right
or what's better for you
than what another doctor may.
That kind of bias affects your
medical judgment and clarity.
Baekhyun, Seulgi, and Jungkook.
Hey Doctor Mike, do you
hear Yanny or Laurel?
I hear Yanny, or Laurel?
[Robot Voice] Laurel.
- Oh, I heard Laurel, something
to do with frequency of hearing
and I heard it's something
to do with how old you are?
But I'm only 28 and I hear Laurel,
which is supposed to be for older folks.
Scientists, explain it to me!
DMS2, do you use a squatty potty?
Using one as I type.
Gross, TMI, but no, I
don't use a squatty potty.
I don't think you have
to raise up your legs
in order to poop effectively.
I think that's a marketer trying
to sell you a piece of plastic
to put underneath your toilet
because they're an IKA marketer expert.
If you don't know what an
IKA marketer expert is click
and watch my Ted Talk.
Regina Phalange, Regina
Phalange, that's from Friends!
- I'm Regina Phalange.
- So how should we clean our ears?
What is the right way?
Regina, the right way is
to only clean the outside of your ears.
You can use Q-tips, but they
have to be on the outside.
Inserting anything into
your ears is a huge no-no.
The problem is with a Q-tip
is they push the earwax
further in, they irritate the canal,
and those are things you don't wanna do.
If you feel like you have a lot of earwax,
you have two options.
One, go to a pharmacy and pick
up some over-the-counter
earwax dissolving solution.
You can put some drops in.
It'll take a few days and
it'll dissolve the earwax
and it'll come out naturally on its own.
Or two, go see your family medicine doctor
and we have a lot of tools that we can use
to clean out your ears and
get the earwax out safely
without irritating your canals
or hurting your tympanic membrane,
which is the part of the
middle ear that helps you hear.
Emily Z, every time I watch you,
I feel like I've grown a brain cell.
(laughing) Well Emily, you
don't really grow brain cells.
But what you're doing is you're
strengthening the contacts
between your neurons, which allows you
to piece the information that I'm putting
in your brain now and allow
it to be accessed later
so you can make better
decisions about your health.
(mimics explosion) ReeseGirl50Plays,
what are your thoughts on makeup?
And do you think it's okay for young teens
to wear pounds of it everyday?
There's probably nothing wrong with it.
I'm not a huge fan of makeup.
I get that you have to wear makeup
for television when I do TV.
They do put makeup on.
Making sure that you take
it off every night is smart.
So you don't clog your pores
and become prone to breakouts.
But otherwise, I think it's fun.
As long as you're not doing it
for any negative reasons that
like you have body dysmorphic disorder
and you hate the way you look
or something along those lines,
then it's just a creative outlet
that you can use to express yourself.
Love Charlie, what causes hiccups?
Is there a way to stop
them once they start?
(horse hiccups, woman laughs)
Hiccups is just a little spasm going on
in your diaphragm, which is the muscle
immediately below your lungs.
The way that works for
me to cure hiccups is
to eat a spoonful of sugar.
It's so weird, but it works for me!
I don't know what the medical reasoning
for it is, but it works.
Other things that I've
heard in the past is
if you chug a full glass of
water tilting your head back,
someone scaring you,
but really the spoonful
of sugar has always worked for me!
It's like 100% effective for me.
It's worked for my friends.
I mean as long as you're not diabetic
and you're not doing anything crazy,
maybe try it for yourself?
Casey B, Mike is so cute.
Wow, I can't believe he's real.
He's probably a hologram.
I promise I am not a
hologram. (clears throat)
Alonzo Barrientos, do a draw my life.
Alonzo, I wanna do a draw my life!
If anyone knows a great animator
who can help me out with that,
please tag them below in the comments,
send them an email because
I really can't draw
to save my life.
You don't wanna draw me
life from me doing it.
Amoret, you should do medical ASMR.
You know I've seen some
of these ASMR things.
They're like people like
(rubbing fingers together)
doing noises like this
right? (scratches beard)
Is this a medical ASMR? (rubbing shirt)
(whispers) Hello.
(whispers) Adele, can
you hear me now? (laughs)
Marcos Vinicius Garcia
Lazaro, hey Doctor Mike,
big fan, I have to use
the microwave every day
to heat my lunch at work.
Is there any risk by doing that?
No, there's no risk.
Don't worry about microwaves,
period, end of story.
Don't go on any of these crazy websites
where people are like "Microwaves
are gonna cause cancer
"and kill you."
Yes, don't stand in front of the microwave
for long periods of time.
Use it, don't be afraid of it.
If there comes out some breaking story
where we find out that microwaves are bad
for you because of proven research,
I will be one of the first people
to tell you that and you will
see it all across the news.
You know, as I say, be alert, not anxious.
Hey, doc, I recently
went through something
where a few surgeons changed my life
for the better and
honestly I'm so thankful.
I feel like I owe them my life.
What are some good ways to
thank medical professionals?
Gifts, thank you letters,
just a verbal thanks
or anything else?
Love your videos.
Very happy to hear that you
had a positive medical outcome
from your surgeons.
Do something like this.
It's called a letter of gratitude.
Write a letter to whichever doctor
that you think helped you along
your journey thanking them,
expressing your gratitude, being as open
and honest as possible
and don't send it to them.
Either make an appointment to see them
or just drive by and for a social visit
and read the letter out loud to them.
Not only is that gonna
be incredibly powerful
for them, but it's gonna
be powerful for yourself.
In fact, we've seen
the letter of gratitude
as a psychological
experiment decrease symptoms
of anxiety and depression in people
for three, four weeks, six
weeks after reading the letter.
Write a letter of
gratitude and let me know
down below how that
whole process works out.
You've done an amazing job asking me
some really tough questions!
And you're helping me
stay sharp as a doctor
as much as I'm helping you
gain more medical wisdom.
So keep your questions coming!
Keep the humor coming.
I'm really enjoying it.
As always, stay happy and healthy!
(upbeat music)